you can start now thank you so much
okay thank you sonalika and um
omix logic group for inviting me
and uh welcome to all the participants
and um i will give you a myself sanji
and i'm the director in biocos life
sciences we do a lot of computations
and a lot of research in computational
biology genomics basically and we are
based in bangalore about 13 years old
company
so with that i will
introduce you with very basic single
cell and spatial transcriptomics and
other data types
so let me start
so
this is the presentation flow
let me check my pen is working
yes
fine
so this will be the presentation flow i
will give you ngs in journal because
many steps overlap with even single cell
so i will make a background quickly
and uh 8 to 10 minutes then i will tell
you single cell what yn methods in
analysis
[Music]
fine
and then single cell transcriptome
uh basically single cell rna sequencing
and then a spatial single cell i will
give you the basics
and i will also try to get to the very
you know on new ones in the field with
the very tentative layman kind of
explanations how it is
then single cell epg epigenetics
basically atac
which is basically adapted from the bulk
epigenetics protocols to the
single cell then i will drive time
permits to run some of the tools and
give you demo and tell about them
so in basic when we are talking about
ngs
uh if you see the history for singer
methods and somewhere dna microarrays
some of us we have very widely worked on
them
and
that was the very high throughput first
time
and then after that the field was
revolutionized by illumina sort
sequencing which came somewhere around
2008 then now we are on the single
molecule sequencing and single cell
which is the third generation
now if you see here various protocols uh
if you see here these are all dna
and there are decide is rna protocols so
we can analyze a lot of
like variants
the end targeted like exome and glicons
and then we have basically epigenetics
protocol single cell and a lot of rna
transcriptomics and targeted rna and
small rnas
so if we look at
the whole
bunch of
analysis required for the
genetics now if you see this is
basically a epi genetics block here
which is in red so if you see mostly
these are the regulatory elements like
mnesec
the
dnas firey sex
chipset and then
uh occupancy of
you know dna which is adac sec
which is basically
assays with transposes accessible
chromatin what is accessible and if you
see this side basically this blue side
this is basically
the transcriptome
rna seq so
and
you can see the transcripts variants and
mutations
so with the now invent of these ngs
protocols
we can analyze the whole spectrum of
dna from epigenetics changes to
regulatory changes and transcriptome
now there are hundreds
in fact more than hundreds of protocols
now if you see here this is basically
dominated by gene expression or any
biology and genome regulation but you
see a lot of small small new protocols
like including single cells they are
coming up
so
there are so many protocols are coming
which use which are using ngs
now if we see at the ngs flow basically
it is
uh three steps prepare your library
sequence and then analyze
so it depends what is your
biological material
which you are trying to address
so it can be single cell or it can be a
bulk
and the protocol
first extract the dna then library
preference preparation matters on what
is your
biology question and what is your
material like single cell or bulk or rna
or gypsy
then you amplify it and then sequence
like elimina
or
me set and once it is sequenced the raw
image comes and then one then after that
the read comes
here
and these reads are aligned to the
reference genome
here
and once they are in alive and aligned
then down the line when you are
analyzing then you can see various
you know protocol depending on your
analysis rnac transcriptome or variants
or protein dna interaction epigenetics
can you can infer and then downstream
analysis like networks and all kind of
things can be done
so basically this is the ngs flow and
this is a common flow most of the
protocols
including single cell or
so these are the sequencer i'm just
rushing through the briefly uh you may
be knowing all these things like
illumina everybody's nose
uh
specific biosciences long reeds oxford
nano
four which is also long read and there
are three types actually sort read long
read and directly dis has come
so
these are the three types of sequencing
mechanisms
now the what is the basic philosophy you
take the fragments so these are the
fragments and they are breaking
they are broken
and then they are sequenced
and once you sequence the these are
called reeds and you get the reeds
now these reeds
here you can see they are barcoded
basically index
uh here in bulk uh you know rna or
chipseek they are basically to decipher
the samples you can run in together and
then later you can de-multiplex so this
is basically but later you will see in
single cell
we will see
we will need different kind of tags
so once it is tagged
then you have the read you can sequence
from the one end or you can sequence
from the both the end so this is your
fragment
which was fragmented and amplified in
pcr so you can take a single entry or
you can take both the ends so you get
the pair end reads
and this part basically is not sequenced
that's that's the way
these ngs protocols win over sanger
sequencing because you don't have to
sequence from one end to other and it's
statistically because you have millions
or millions of reads so they
cover whole genome that's the idea
whether we are
winning over cost winning over time
now once you have sequenced either both
ends or single n then you get this
faster q file
once you get a faster q file which is
basically the four lines so this is your
read one end or both end if it is both
end two files will get one in
read one and the e2 and then you have
the quality once you have the quality
which is spread quality check eight and
it has to be above 30 and nowadays
sequences are very much good so even
people are taking 40 it depends on your
protocol like variance it has to be
higher depth and better quality
in chipseek you can survive with the
lesser one
so once you once we have got the faster
queue and with better quality
then the next one is we align to the
reference genome this is your reference
and this reads are aligned to the
reference and once it is aligned you can
compare like here you can see the
variants so once they are compared then
we can analyze variants or other
protocols the other protocols are like i
have told you the variant detection so
you see the statistically how much is
the coverage and
with statistically how much is the p
value then you can see whether g's
variant a is there here or not
this is basically your variant detection
the other one is the rna-seq this is the
bulk one then you have a sample one in
sample two as you know this is the
digital
compared to the fluorescence microarray
so here you see the pile say for example
these are the 20 and the sample two this
is say three so now if you see this is
gene one
so this gene one here
uh you can see is the expressed in
sample 1 but it is not in sample 2
right
so
based on the p value so you can detect
rna
this is
transcriptome the expression gene
expression
and then in chipset more than count we
are bothered about the pattern if it is
a pattern then it means the protein is
binding on a dna as you know the
transcription factors in it how the
protein interacts with dna is very much
analyzed using the chipset
so the vc the pattern so basically these
three kind of protocols are
mainly the applications of ngs but they
are in bulk
now as i go to the single cell before
that let me tell you the what is the
mrna or rna set this is the bulk one
just
uh to give you the background so you
have a sample of interest
disease tumor or something then you have
rna molecules they are fragmented then
here you see they are basically adapters
are added they are the barcodes and then
when you sequence so you have a read one
and the two and then you have the
adapters and once you remove these
adapters so you can get read one and
this is read two which are aligned to
the genome and there are some
complexities when you align on the you
know because
uh cdna when taken from
rna mrna there are the breaks which are
introns are spliced out in that that i'm
not going to discuss once it is aligned
and
then we can do the data analysis like
desect 2
then hd count and various other methods
um lima and all kind of things so you
can use differential expression variant
calling annotations and novel
transcripts and editing
now
with this background i have covered very
quickly the ngs uh
protocols now we are going to go to
single cell now that's what we have um
today's
talk
so i hope you have you know got the idea
what is ngs how it is different in
single cell that will be we will see so
if we look at the layman type of
analogy suppose this is a kind of a big
game like olympic then you see hundreds
of countries
and you know thousands and thousands of
players
now how you evaluate a player
performance and how you identify
so let me say that player is like a cell
so first one is pull a player out
okay so that is isolation
correct
now once you pull a player out
how are you going to analyze it now you
have to tag it first one is you have to
identity that is the player name right
then you have a country which is its
special location
and then what is the action what he has
won that is basically his achievement
expression in some sense you can
analogically you can
compare that is medals what is his
performance now you need three texts
right one two and three to identify
the player name which is something like
a cell barcode which are nothing but
micro particles beads you might have
heard in single cell there are beads
where there is a cell then you have um
unique molecular identifiers they are
like a transcript like your rna mrna and
then you have a special location in some
of the sequencing based spatial analysis
so with this you know layman example how
you
infer anything
basically especially in
time excess any object in the nature is
something like that so we have to
analyze the cells also like that
now
cells in multiple context as in previous
example i have shown you a one player
now if you see here they are in multiple
dimensions they work like environmental
stimuli like you can see a blue cell
here
so let's see
and it goes in cell development cell
cycle and spatial context like a micro
environment in the tumor progression and
so if you see the cell is not a static
object like earlier we were you know
analyzing so now if you see here that we
are seeing the five dimensions the first
one you have a discrete type you have to
see what kind of of cells are there
right
so there may be a rare cell die
the other one is the continuous
phenotype regulatory so they get
inflammatory
and that kind of changes happens to the
cell even in
they change their functionality
when they are in a cancer or something
like that and then you have the temporal
at the time changes like stem cells they
differentiate into different kinds so
and then vesilation when they are
revisiting so there are multiple
dimensions then another one
once you have found a discrete types
here the cell types then how you can
map it back to the histological sections
from where they are got
that is basically a special position as
you know it's very important like in
tumor
and
emt and that kind of what kind of
collagens and how they are in matrix how
they are so
even in other contexts it's very
important
so i hope that gives you the background
like how it is important and what kind
of cell multiple contexts are there and
why people are trying
to you know like single cell spatial
and
trajectories and all kind of things
because that's the way in for the full
whole functionality
now
why we need it now if you see here as
you see adipose tissues they are made up
of different type of cells
so
almost everywhere you will find tissues
and organs they are very different types
of cells they are made up of and they
interact
so then you have it now peripheral blood
that is now if you see on this now
if you take an average here
none of the cell is
basically depicted their behavior as a
while
by the averaging
that's why we cannot infer that what
kind of
behavior is happening for example let me
tell you a realistic situation we faced
so a few years back
we have a project which was a brain
tissue of mouse so there was a cell
and they were dying basically in that
particular disease and there were so
many cells so let's say these are
hundred and they were say five
so when we analyzed transcriptome so
this basically it was coming because it
was cumulative bulk and because the
cells were individually there
you know individually very high but when
it comes bulk it was coming because
there were hundreds and they were dying
and this was the problem basically and
that time let me tell you we couldn't do
single cell it's a pretty old 2008-10
project
so
that time we realized how to capture
only these cells transcriptome
and today i realized that it was very
important so i hope you understand why
it is needed in such situations
especially brain where the you know the
cells are very much localized in
different areas of the brain
so
same way in the disease cases you see
you will find a disease in specific
cells
once you find disease specific cells
then you can infer what kind of you know
you can have the targets or the you know
therapeutic therapeutics but it is
important to decipher what kind of cells
are so the single cell analysis is
enabling nowadays
as it is coming
very much to decipher these kind of
questions which we could not address
now single cell it was earlier also if
we look at the traditional single cell
it was microscopy cytometry nowaday
nowadays it is also there
i'm just rushing through some slides
because i have a lot of things to cover
so you see
uh the the challenges were throughput
and number of features we can and the
cost was very high you can see 35
per cell 35 dollars and one dollar even
so
these things can be used but
how you scale it up to the genome wide
you can analyze few cells hundreds and
thousands but how you can million in
trillion cells how can you analyze that
is the aim basically
now if you see then the single cell
platform came initially it was 2008 when
the technology clicked and 2009
basically uh that was manual tank that
page nature paper then nowadays like
whatever's 10x is using very much drop
set and 10x
so you will see the nano droplets
uh drop set
so these are various and the these
things will come again and again so i
will just
go through so basically drop set
and the 10x i will just explain some of
them
okay
so now
uh there are basically four types one is
the facts fluorescence activated cell
sorting droplet base nanowarp and none
so if you see here number of cells per
essay you can compare here it is high
actually but
you can see this is basically very much
widely used in a lot of publications
dropsec and the chromium
10x technology so you can see here they
are basically pretty high not at the
topmost but
they are used and they are droplet based
so i will explain you some of these
concepts
uh here it is just these methods so what
is the flow it will come again and then
so let me just move to the next slide it
will come how it is done
uh it is another comparison slide if you
see in drop set so
here you can see umi and full length so
some are um i and full and some are not
able to full length and that just three
prime end or something like that um
so what are the challenges before we go
to
some of the technology you know
technically explaining the top things
now one first one is cell isolation how
you isolate the cell it may
you know change the behavior of the cell
like magnetic or by mechanical force or
by enzymatically so that will change the
course of the
your cell it may change the behavior so
that is the one challenge another one is
the amplification because you are at a
single cell so it is very small material
so how this amplification is done that
is another challenge and the throughput
how you increase to you know thousands
and thousands and million cells how can
you so high throughput so these are the
basically the major three challenges
cell isolation amplification and
parallel processing how can do various
steps so that you can bring down the
cost time
and
on the same time increase the throughput
sorry i got back now next challenge is
sensitivity versus
[Music]
sensitive versus
how you can have the
quality
and quantity so now if you see smartsec
it is manual here you can cover
uh you know genes i will show you the
matrix but here you will drop some of
the genes like you know the features but
this is high throughput
now the next challenge is
basically at the data level
so if you see the major problem is drop
out events other one is because of
dispersion biological dispersion because
they are very different types of cells
may be there then high magnitude
outliers may be there
but if you see this is the one of the
challenge because when you see the
matrix which will come expression matrix
it is lot of zeros
so it is very sparse and your gene may
be expressing but it may be dropped out
that is the another challenge how to
meet and
minimize
that
particular problem
so uh with this kind of introduction and
challenges and why it is needed let me
get through the steps
how it is done single cell sequencing so
the first step is cell isolation so
there are you can see here you can see
here there are various ways so you can
have you know manual
you can have fluorescence activated cell
sorting here then you have
you can have uh antibody based
immunopanning
then you can have a magnetic based
then laser
capture micro dissection and then micro
fluids which is drop set
and widely used so let me
take one which is 10x and chromium they
are using this is
microfluids
now here are two types this is
dropship
if you see here
and he's this is high throughput the
another one is targeted
and that is specs
smart set
two
so let me take this high throughput
here this is a basic flow so first
through the laser you have separated the
cells then this is drop set and or in
drop this is 10x chromium
or smart set as on previous slide i have
shown
this is less throughput but both the
ends are sequenced so you can do more
things but
the throughput is less here if you see
here only the three prime end is
sequenced and you can detect some of the
gene expression and things like that so
this is the basically basic flow
now these are the steps and i will
explain you each one of them in little
more detail so first you have a cell i
told you then you disassociate with the
cell isolation which i have shown you on
the previous slide then this is the drop
sec so your cell comes and your this is
the droplets beads
and they will encapsulate your cells so
some are waste
like empty it will go this is also one
another problem and you know people are
trying to minimize this the but
the thing is your cell is come with the
b
and once it is isolated your left then
you have to license then you have to put
a barcode on next slide i will explain
you once you have done the barcode your
library is prepared and then it goes for
the sequencing and once sequencing is
done as i told you in ngs then you get a
faster q file
of pure
remember as i told in the player example
now you see various
tags umi bar code and you will see the
other tags
so these texts are used later to
segregate cell wise or transcript wise
that is the basically a main crux so
this is the drop set which i have told
you now if you see just i will i would
like to
you know explain you how is this
uh droplet works so if you see this is
the bead
basically then it has you can see pcr
handle cell barcode and
unique molecular identifier basically it
will catch your
transcript
so this is the droplet now it has
hydrogels and primers it is packed with
this this bead then when cell comes here
then
your
when you lyses them this is your mrna
transcripts they will get attached to
them
right
so you have three handles now pcr handle
cell so you can segregate self from this
and um i basically you can sketch these
particular things so if you have cell
one two three four and then your library
is prepared so that's the way in a
droplet base the b the sorry droplets
are formed and how they capture your
transcripts basically
now this is
that first a i have explained you this
is the beat now if you remember how you
generate basically bar codes so you can
generate
there are different
ways like combinatorics and things like
that so 12 bases you can generate so
month
and eight basis for umi remember these
are text
unique tags so this is the way how it is
explained like how many which is around
65 k
so you can analyze you can take so many
cells
right
and the next one
a this is the full flow whatever i
explained so you take your cells in your
drop then you get
you know captured your
cells with the bead then the mrna
is
again i'm repeating just for
sake of you know understanding the full
process then it is attached to it once
it is attached here these are called
stems then you can do pcr and then after
sequencing you get the file
first active file your reads
now when you get a fastacu file it will
your reads will come like this after
sequencing then you have two barcodes
cell barcode in umi and this is anyway
your sequence
now based on barcode cell barcode you
can segregate
your transcripts
in cell and based on your
umis you can the finally
your matrix gene expression matrix for
each gene you have a cell then you will
have a count how many so cell one say
like you have three
so
in like you have a here are the genes so
you can see some of the genes here for
example
uh you have this and you have this here
so it is expressing in cell one and it
is not expressing it is there the
transcript is there that we have to see
whether it is expressing or not so
finally what you get is the
expression
matrix
which is different if you remember
express and matrix let me
explain on the next slide
so
we have come to the expression matrix so
so far what i have
basically explained is
what is the single cell protocols
right now if we apply this is a single
cell rna-seq you might have heard a lot
now if you see why it is needed if you
have a tissue
now it is a bulk expression
and here it is cell wise expression as i
already i told you like why it is needed
when your cell specific expression is
needed in certain answering some
some of the biological questions so it
is very important in certain situation
now if you look at the
rna-seq bulk rna seq our matrix
expression matrix was
like this
we have genes and then we have samples
you know so we were telling okay disease
sample non-disease normal sample whether
this gene is expressing or not but we
were not talking about the cell but if
you see in the
you know
single cell here you have a gene
then you have cells so in this cell
basically this gene is not there by the
cell so these are the
cells cell 2 which are responsible for
dna expression so now we can
basically specify like these transcripts
in particular gene and these are the
cells responsible so please see
carefully the difference in whatever
your expression matrix comes and this
will go down the line for the analysis
so they are the basically the four steps
in single cell rna sequencing let me
tell you the first one is the sample
preparation which i think we have
already
uh i have already talked about it first
this aggregation of cell isolation and
remove
separating them mechanically and
geometrically
or filtering whatever way various ways
are there then you get the single cell
then you use facts droplets and nano
walls once you have got the cells and
like i have shown you the
droplets then you add the barcode cell
barcode now i hope you understand what
is um in cell barcode which are helping
to segregate your transcripts and cells
from where it is come
now you can have segmentation or
fragmentation pcr then library
like preparation which is 3 prime or 5
prime or it can be full because this is
10x and there are the other protocols
10x only
you know sequence the three prime end
then you sequence it can be parent or
single end mostly the parent nowadays
because the cost has come down
now the third step is once as i told you
you get the file
then you de-multiplex it cell wise
then you align to the reference genome
and then you get the matrix
then after that you can have the various
analysis here
that i will show you down the line a few
of them insure it when i will say the
arc port
so this is the basic flow
of rna sequencing now in the data
analysis down you can
special
uh tissue reconstruction yes that is
done from the sequencing in fact from
scr nsf sewaret is doing then you can do
clustering in marker identification
what is the expressions are happening
then you can have a dimension reduction
and see the cells the another one is you
can see on the timeline how the
trajectories of your cells how they are
propagating
in pseudo time
so these are the various analysis can be
done with your single cell data analysis
now in summary we can say once you have
as a bioinformatician you have
expression matrix which are cell versus
gene remember this is not sample versus
gene as in bulk then you have a feature
selection yes you have to sort out you
know what are the differentially
expressed and
you know that's why you can see some is
which may not be useful you have to
check it out
then dimensionality reduction and after
that you can see cell cell distance you
can see various things especially map
them
or cluster them and
networks and all that kind of things can
be done
now this is all flow which i have
explained
so to add to that the previous slide
this is the full flow slide then you can
have differential expressions then you
can have cell cell interaction networks
you might have seen in various nature in
other papers
then you can have associated association
association with sample phenotypes
what healthy was it disease what are the
cells and then you can have regulatory
networks
now
i have uh done so far the single cell
rna seq now i will show you the basic uh
you know various technologies and
protocols for spatial single cell this
is the basic thing in emerging area i
think very much again just to see the
analogy now the picture is the perfect
if you take your picture of your house
then you know where is what right so the
picture is the best
and for a special location but the
problem is you cannot take picture of
all the rna and old genome bite
and this is like you know face
or
inside to hybridization or fluorescence
based but
what we are looking at the genome white
means can we cover the whole genome
now if you do the sequencing we are lost
like we have taken from here and fill in
a box that's what you have taken the
cells and you lose the from where it
came
so what is the one basic method can be
done you take them
basically now another barcode will come
which is especially in tissue section so
we can put another tag
and once they are mixed now i can locate
from my tissue if i have a section so i
have say for example this or this i know
from where it came
so that is the one of the idea how the
special
uh sequence mapping is done basically in
single cells so we take especially and
then we can
infer them
now this is timeline so if you see many
here 10x chromium uh they are basically
droplets um inside to capture
technologies mixture then you see lot of
like this is
america's or
basically sack face these are amazing
based so if you see the green ones
so
like if you see here in there some are
sequencing base like star map
and
like tom said
there's geosec here
so
basically four or five types of
you know
special mapping technologies and they
have a some good some bad nothing is
ideal
so
this is a very cluttered slide
um just to check um
yes i'm there everybody is there hello
sonalika
hello
yes sir yes
yeah you are there with me right
okay
yeah good and i hope you are following
right
okay fine so
now if you see the spatial analysis this
is bit cluttered slide but it has
everything and i will
take slices of it to explain but let me
show you the whole
uh view
so we have a these are the imaging based
if you see the first top left
and then high throughput cell sequencing
based and then these are the hybrid like
you take amazing profile like sewerage
it takes the um sdr nsx and it takes the
imaging profile
basically the face
and then it can reconstruct
so the these are various kind of like in
terms of if you see even bulk rna is
used not even single cell and then you
have the somehow the special data
uh triangulated in
you know that information is embedded to
that this kind of technology so there
are various emerging technologies which
are using bulk rna and from
you know that cell atlas or somewhere it
is given and then how to merge integrate
data or use the drop set and uh scrnsec
data and isc face or some imaging data
and they re reconstruct the spatial
location of those cells
so
now if we
the basically there are four types
one is in silico as i told you they take
the rna sequencing scrna and the fish
data and they try to
re
map it
especially now but cannot match
coordinate intent to simplify basically
that's what simplify and you get that
kind of thing the next one is laser
capture micro dissection in that
you have a limitation this is few cells
you can do then inside you this is an
imaging based
so you have phase or various four or
five times four or five types are there
and then you have a rna imaging this is
also i think pretty much emerging
detects only targeted transcripts so
everyone has a good
and some bad
pros and cons
now if you look at it the four types i
have told you so first you take rna-seq
it's just a flow to just show you in the
image the previous slide it explores the
previous slide and then you have it
inside to hybridization
and then uh there is a suret here which
is hidden behind it now it will
basically you can take this part and
integrate with this
and it is very easy pipeline in sierra
in fact you can explore it the next one
is basically the lcm sec and geosec
based
there you can see it is a sequencing
based uh using the barcodes
and the third one it is amazing based
basically
this is
merfis
which is basically
multiplex error robust fish
this is also pretty much
you know used
so this is imaging based and the next
one the last one fourth one is you can
see here spatial ids the barcodes are
added you take the slices and you add
the barcodes and then sequence
so basically the four types one
computational methods first one lcm
based then rna amazing and then i inside
to sequencing methods so four types of
now there are two things we have talked
about one is you have a single cell
sequencing here
the other part which i have
shown you this is special
so
now a good amount of challenges how you
can integrate this data you will see lot
of papers and how so that you can better
infer
the
biology whatever the questions you are
inferring if you
these two things how they can be merged
and there is the various you know
technologies if you see here lcm
so if you see the gene measured are very
high but if you see the x-axis is cells
and this is gene measured okay
throughput of cells or spots so now if
you see they are very good in
sensitivity they can measure genes but
you can analyze only very less cells
but if you see the other they are pros
and cons and these some are just
computational based these are the
algorithms here you can see
in the other many if you are seeing
these things there are imaging based
murphys four five six it is evolving
so uh all kind of these technologies
with plus miners and that kind of thing
various things are there
and this is the
barcoding strategy which i'm not going
to go into deep but
uh various phase sm phase nerf is and
that kind of thing of the bar coding as
i have explained you
now what we have done so far to
summarize we did the bulk
rna set then we have a single cell and
we got the
you see here we got the gene and sample
wise and then here we got the matrix
then we have a special section we have
taken and we have mapped
either through imaging or through
computationally we have reconstructed
the tissue
sections with the cell mapping so we
have covered these three things
okay
now
let me get to the single cell
epigenetics sc 80 asap
because it's a simple one and it is
adapted
for the single cell analysis there are
chipseq
and other protocols now when you look at
the epigenetic profile you have a three
regions basically if you have the
chromatin accessibility then you have a
protein dna interactions then you have a
dna methylation basically like in cancer
and things like that now if you see for
chromatin
accessibility you have mnas dnas pyramid
and new one which is atic which is
essays for transposes accessible
chromatin and i'm going to cover this
one for the epigenetics which is adapted
basically for the single cell and i will
little give you the tools and things
like that now if here is the comparison
all
basically the chromatin accessibility
the first chipset and that also you can
use dna
set and mr
mnas and pyrite now if you can see here
no sonification is needed as it is
needed here it is just
endonuclease tn5
then you have a segmentation
so this is just a comparison slides of
various uh you know things and in fact
they are not exclusive they help each
other you cannot answer all the
questions with one protocol
basically so what is athc this is for
transposes accessible chrome maintain so
it will
uh give you what is the chromat
chromatin is accessible as you know that
is what is the regulation happens so you
have a this is basically uh not uh
what you say like mutated kind of
transposes nucleus 5 and it is like a
cutting paste when it comes it will cut
and paste your fragment here
and that it will segmentation so it will
basically like capturing your accessible
chromatin once it comes so you have
barcode primers
here
and then you can see we have got
that segment we can filter and take it
out then we amplify and then you put
barcodes whatever
you know this bar codes and umis are
very important to later access the
particular
information or the segment what then it
goes to the next generation sequencing
so basically you can use
this
um
i'm not talking about single cell it is
basically a normal even normal
now
if you in a layman language if you can
tag you can take a single cell chromatic
and then you can have the like scr and
asset you can tag single cell here then
again you can do the similar thing as we
have done in single cell rnac
now what is the prone
pros of this it is very fast in fact
simple and sensitive you can see three
hours otherwise it takes days
and it works on many cell types
and requires no sonification phenol
chloroform
like pyrite you and antibodies you know
these all processes in chipseek or
firearms
they create the bias
and the the last thing which is it is
modified for single cell analysis
which it is very difficult for the other
that's why you see 10x chromatin
uh they have used this protocol the
other cones is basically it is cells
must be optimized if you have two less
and two high cells it won't give the
good performance and you can do all kind
of
some of these you know epigenetics
analysis nuclear mapping transcription
factor occupancy identification of novel
enhancers in deep study of the genomic
profiles
so
this is somewhat um
you can see in the picture basically
what i have explained so here is atsec
and then after that you can
see the picture sorry peaks
here and on the with your reference
genome so you can see where it is
binding uh
basically where it is binding the your
enhancer in something like
this kind of questions you can answer
like suppose it is a healthy your here
is your binding your enhancer and
suppose the mutation happens it doesn't
bind okay so you can address such
disease whether see it is epigenetics
and whether it is binding or not binding
so that kind of
questions you can answer with this kind
of protocol
what some of the things i'm telling you
can do many other things basically now
uh till here uh we have 10 minutes let
me i think we will be able to finish
so
i have covered quite a few things uh
three four things now there are tools
right you have pseudo monocle and snap
it
one tool i have taken there are many
actually so i will explain you quickly
what can be done with these tools and
how they work
in fact this uret was the first and very
famous and it is used so basically what
they do they demultiplex and read
alignment
and uh not this unit it is done by cell
ranger that next slide i will explain
then basically they will quantify and
data filter and data normalize once they
normalize then you can see the reads and
cells that matrix comes once you get
that matrix you can do so you see here
genes and cells then you can do pca
you map
t sign it
you know reduction you can have
hierarchical clustering and then you
have marker genes detection
right differentially expressed genes in
which cells and things basically this is
what mostly and then you have a monocle
3 which gives you the dynamic gene
expression in inference the trajectories
rna velocity basically
so the flow is the first part
as you know i have told you the pasta q
file you get from the sequencer then you
have align cell barcode and umi counting
is done then you get the matrix uh this
is the very computationally intensive
process
and you need a big machines and the cell
ranger will give you this and i think
it's freely available then you can use
it then once you get the feature barcode
matrix then you can do cell
identification as already we have talked
different types of cell you can have
trajectories
and you can have the differentially
expressed genes so
cirrhed here monoclonal three and
curette can do this in fact this surat
has for
uh atsx single cell analysis also they
have incorporated in fact it is evolving
they are adding
day by day new features whatever we have
explained the five six dimensions so if
you see insurance even
analysis of special data sets you see
they map if you have availability of
spatial data set it can be mapped to
your single cell or any sequencing data
or chipset data
then you can do other things like
quality rna differential gene
expressions
and
the next one is monoplay there you can
see basically the trajectory it came
and this is a snap atac that
i won't show you in the running
but here you can see the main part
others are normalization even you see in
gypsy
but the differentiating part for single
cell is you have the clustering cell
wise and this is the basically the main
part peak calling
where is the binding is happening rest
is the different analysis you can see
pseudo time and everything one city you
have a data single cell you can
run on anything
so now let me give you a quick demo
okay
so
hello everybody is there
hello
yes sir yes yes go ahead we are
following yes sir yes so
i will just quickly share the another
screen
so
um
[Music]
so basically this is the re studio
and easily you can you know build
are you able to see my screen this
hello can you see my code
yes sir yes sir yes you can see yes
called cody so this is the basically let
me show you the first sewer it
was run
so just to save time
so basically how quickly let me show
first you take the sewerage and this is
the r studio you can install
i'm on
ubuntu 20.04
so
these are the some of the libraries
which are used by it and it will tell so
let me run it step by step
okay
so these are and then package see right
if you are aware of the r and the
packages so easily and if you go in
tools here and you say install packages
and
uh you can just type here suret
and it will come just click and say
install is not that but you may
stuck in some dependencies uh then you
have to resolve them
[Music]
basically i have to go to the code
directory so
fine
then
first read the data and
let me tell you this data i have
downloaded it is already data in that
site and it comes for the cell ranger
10x data
library and
this is like that matrix bar course umis
and there are three files basically
which is going to use so
we have taken the data now
it has one three seven one four features
you can you can look at it here
if you look at it here
it is showing the output here what is
going to come in
the figures will come in the right panel
then
so now you can see here
like
zoom plot
your data here so different kind of
like various things you can plot
okay
so
let me see the other these are just
features of how your data is scattered
and things like that
then the first step you have to
normalize the data and you can use
various methods if you just see the help
on this you have different parameters so
the first step is after first step read
the data which is from 10x cell ranger
it comes just to summarize the you know
the steps then here basically the here
you normalize the data
once it is normalized
then
you have find variable features
basically it will find
your
like
genes and features in that
then you can see that
let me just plot and i can show you
[Music]
something like this so
variance average expression it will show
then after that um
you have to scale the data
just to you know
it will take a while it is done
then
you have to do the dimension reduction
linear this is pca or
um it supports all here is a pca you can
say you map also
so it will support those
various dimensional you know reductions
then you can plot this is pca see here
it is pca here
okay
which i have highlighted you can have
umap and so it will show you different
pc1 and pc2 it is showing two principal
components if you are aware like you
know dimensional reductionality the
first two three components of principal
component analysis they give you most of
the data that's the idea actually it's
something like you have a lot of data
and you have segregated the main data
into the one corner of your room suppose
it is scattered on your house on the
floor then you choose what is the
important and pile up in the one corner
in a layman language i am telling you
principal component analysis is
something like that so it will your
important you know information it will
in first two three components it will
segregate that's the dimensional
reductionality okay
then you can see the heat map these are
just you know
this is pc earlier you saw the different
plot it is a different plot
then you have the another heat map like
you know
so you can see the various ways
um
this was giving
okay
i want to show you the umap
just wait a while it is processing it
takes time
so now you can see here now you have got
your cells basically eight types
so this is you map
right
uniform manifold approximation and
projection if you are aware of that and
mainly the you may have insinity you map
is in some cases
it works better than sanity so
now you have eight clusters basically
these are the clusters you can see the
clusters eight clusters here then you
can see the cells here
the next one
now
that is the differential gene expression
it has shown the head if you uh
you know
no here let me highlight with the mouse
this one you can see it has given you
the basically these are the markers they
are calling it they will not
differentiate basically the markers so
you see the gene list here then you see
the lock fc p values like you have seen
in a bulk
rna seek and the cell wise it will be
so
basically that's what he's doing now
there are eight clusters in markers the
gene it basically it is attaching the
genes now you can see the genes
differentially expressed genes so there
are eight clusters
uh
five six seven eight so
uh i think we i can show this only in
two more minutes
i think we are running out of time
anyway we started five minutes late
hello sonalika do i have still time
yes sir please go ahead yes sir please
go ahead so another five minutes let i
want to show you the trajectory also
so
now you can see here if you see the code
we we have given
uh you know
we have given two genes here
cd79a and
a1 now you see the expression of label
in the which cluster it is you see that
in the cluster three and here in this so
you can see the gene and you can see the
cells in that cluster cell wise clusters
so you can see that this gene basically
if you infer the information so this is
the gene and you will find the cluster
of cells like this is the cluster number
three now this gene is expressing in
that cluster so that's the way you infer
that where the genes are which kind of
cells that gene is being expressed now
if you see the code here
we have given these two genes and then
again he is giving the another gene
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so this is the another cells now
sorry genes now if you see here in the
it is expressing
nkf7 in the fourth cluster very high
remember the clusters are cell specific
so now you can find
how the so here if you see this pf4
basically the cluster eight these cells
are responsible
for the majorly expression of pf4
that's what we wanted to find out right
so
that's what
you can get now here
you can see
you know the other
heat maps means various ways that is the
violent plot now you can see the
you have the clusters here i will show
you the uh one so now you see any
particular gene you can take this one so
you can see this is in this particular
cluster so like that you can see the
heat map like this particular gene is
here this type of cells in here l y z
here and how much is the other place
expression majorly these cells but it is
expressing in this so
now uh i think you can realize like how
um
we can get the cell specific information
uh from these data um
right
so
um
cell identity clusters
so you have genes and then you have the
fourth now you can see which genes are
where how they are expressing right the
top zero one two they are say eight
clusters in the other side so what i i
want to demonstrate you that most of
them the things which i have talked
about is just naming the you know cells
you can see here so different cell types
uh clusters eight clusters and you can
see i know b b cells and k cells and
c d four t
like that so whatever i taught you in
the
basically in the presentation now you
can see most of the things coming here
right
and
[Music]
monoplay i'll just run source it fully
and i want to show you the basic you can
have
you know trajectories
it takes a while
i can take questions by the time it the
window will come if you have any
please go ahead if any one of you are
having
some query some question you can reach
me later also let me write my email id
you can take
s a n j double e v
dot
b i o c o s bio
gmail
dot com
that is my id you can
you know reach me any tool or anything
you are
please let me have any questions you
have
or anything else
whatever i have covered so far now one
window will come i will select one cell
and show you the pseudo trajectory
that's it
it takes a while
let it come
anybody has any question or
would like to ask something specific
hello everybody is there
hello
sonalika
hello yes sir yes sir we are here we are
here there is a question that came out
from zara commerce uh and the question
is can we use uret analysis for
bacterial cells
uh yes i think you can
yes sir am i audible to you
yes i'm
yes you are
yes please go ahead
yes basically you can use there is a
i don't think in fact the data what i
have taken is
uh it is some bacterial data only
uh the example what i am showing you
uh
bacterial or
some i think
brain but yes you can use in fact they
have the data example data for it
and there is one more question related
to syrit professor and daniel asks what
package
or what library
is similar to suret that can be used in
python environment
um
actually i am not sure about python
because
i hardly work on that but
[Music]
i'm not sure actually but i don't know
whether cirrit can be used on python or
not
but
i have no idea actually i don't work in
python
but i'm sure i think there must be
adaptation with rappers
maybe offline i can answer if you don't
find or i can tell you some package
which is used in python if you approach
me
but right now um
i have no idea actually in python
whether it works or not or the other
packages
thank you thank you professor and i'm
looking for any other queries
please type in your questions in the
chat box i will read it out to professor
okay there is a question from
radhakrishnan and the question is how is
the cell sorting done using
microfluidics
is it confirmed or validated and how can
we
know which cell type is where
okay
so
for that
so let me finish this i need to go to i
have you know briefly covered that
uh how then droplets basically
uh okay
so just one second let me so here the
screen has come so you can choose
basically which one trajectory you want
this has learned the graph basically so
for example if i take this so you have
to take the start one so i have taken
the start and one i am taking
so i have done
now once it
it is taken
all right
so
if you have taken this is the trajectory
sudo time so i started here if you
remember i marked it here
multiple cells
now how
it is
so the basic you can refine it in fact
much more refined it gives when you set
the parameters but this is the way you
can see the trajectory
in the monocle 3 this is monocle three
with this
let me come to that question so
basically what happens in the droplet
you uh
let me let me stop this
[Music]
so if you go to that to answer that
question
i hope you are able to see my ppt again
yes sir
so
basically
i just
so here this is a actually microfluidic
device
so from one side the cells are pumped
and the other side the beads are
basically in the oil and it encapsulates
the cells inside the bead
it can miss also
so the basically whatever it has
encapsulated
like you can see there is a one beat one
cell type this is cell this is b the
another cell so different types of cells
and beads are coming that's the way it
encapsulate
the cell in a bead basically remember
the bead this is micro particle it has
all the
basically the primers and tags
and once it takes to it then only you
can recognize down the line so
here if you see
first you take uh you know
no this is basically these are like stem
single cell transcriptomes attached to
micro particles
and there can be a miss
like for example if you see once they
are isolated
and i have shown you the isolation
mechanism it can be enzymatic or here it
is through the this droplets so now if
you see this is the only useful single
cell this is the one of the problem
where we miss the many cells so if you
see here only this is it has captured
with the b itself this is empty droplet
it has to be discarded and it has taken
multiple it has to be also discarded
because later you cannot find from this
cell that's come so it misses now the
miss rate is less early it was high so
that's the way
the in the droplets
basically you want to get this attached
this transcriptome to this which has the
primers
and
like if you see here and that's the way
it is
catch and something you miss it is miss
that's the technology right
i hope you i have answered this was your
question
yes sir that that yeah that answers the
question thank you very much
any more questions
i think that will be it yeah i think we
do not have any more question
uh sure and then yeah not related to uh
this topic anyway and uh yeah that the
more questions related to the sessions
and where to access the recordings will
be answered by sonalika later after the
end of this uh
one more session that we have right now
so if there are no more questions please
join me in thanking professor sanjeev
kumar for an enlightening and excellent
presentation and demonstration on a
single cell rna analysis thank you very
much sir thank you very much it's a
pleasure having you here and thank you
very much uh
for your time and for your uh for
sharing your knowledge
uh thank you raghvindra dr
and it was very nice to come here in
this talk
and again i will thank all
all of you full team
and
nicely organizing it thank you very much
so i think you can take the control
yes sir sonalika
okay
thank you so much dr sanji
[Music]
yeah i'm back to the screen
so thank you again and i will stop my
video
and
um
the mic thank you very much
thank you so much sir and now i would
like to pass on the stage to dr
raghavendra to take the session ahead
over to you dr raghavendra
thank you very much
okay let's uh let's move on ahead and uh
after after a wonderful uh
um
talk on single cell rna sequence
analysis by
by professor sanjeev kumar and i feel a
little bit intimidated to talk about the
same uh topic in the context of a turbo
bioinfo platform and how this analysis
analysis can be carried out and
and um yeah how you can perform such an
analysis
using the platforms uh inbuilt tools let
me quickly share my screen and let's go
over the
uh
topics so uh
since professor sajeeb kumar covered
most of these
in in an excellent detail and
and with lot of information
i'm going to and also we are a little
bit short on time so i'm going to
quickly br
glance through or breeze through
some of the
um
concepts that he has already explained
in great detail so uh
welcome to welcome to you all one more
time let me share and yeah
yeah so while you are you you have
already
obtained a lot of inter introduction and
information and explanation regarding
single cell r basic uh data uh single
server basic uh
process so let me let us go through all
of these this will be a very good um
opportunity for you also to summarize
what you have grasped so far in the last
one hour or one and a half hours so uh
while it might seem that single cell
rna-seq is is just a natural step
forward from bulk rna-seq methods but
the complexity and the heterogeneity of
the single cell data as you had already
uh gotten some information or gotten
some introduction to as well as a
significant reduction in the data
quality that that can be recorded uh due
to much less rna material for some
police is too high so as as a result uh
much more emphasis is placed on
normalization and advanced statistical
methods involving machine learning
methods and other
dimensionality reduction methods so
let's uh
let's first understand uh why we need uh
or how um
uh this single cell transcriptomics is
is going to be employed so a single cell
transcriptomics represents the profiling
of all the messenger rnas present in one
cell or present in a single cell so the
most widely used technologies that is
used to perform such profiling are quite
different as you had a lot of
introduction to how and
different and variety of different ways
how these could be performed so they are
widely different than what it is usually
done for bulk rna-seq profiling methods
so unlike the bulk rna-seq profiling
methods where the sequencing libraries
are generated from thousands of cells
and an average expression
analysis of expression data is what is
generated uh by measuring these uh
this bulk rna seek uh the single cell
rna-seq technologies um
isolate single cells by various methods
and then generate cell specific
sequencing libraries by marking the rna
content from a cell with a cell specific
molecular barcode so such such a
technology enables the measurement of
transcriptomic information for a range
of thousands or even up to millions of
single cells in right conditions in
correct conditions so uh
let's go over some of the major
differences between these two
technologies and that includes obviously
the distribution of expression levels
measured as an average for bulk bulk
rna-seq while it is measured at the
individual level for the single rna set
and due to this
scr and ac are more seated to study cell
heterogeneity cell type identification
and the differentiation of cells over
time etc etc so uh
yeah so um
single cell uh technology has been
around only since 2009 so uh it in the
context of
genomics or in the context of
a human genome project which originated
in 90s this is a very recent technology
so relevant publications and protocols
that is
yeah that are
published demonstrate how this
technology has evolved and how this
technology still continues to diversify
because for for fairly recent technology
this has a really variety of ways how
this can how this uh how this profiling
can be achieved and how this analysis
can be performed um so separating
tissues into cells as a biotechnological
or biotech technological or micro
biological
protocols has been around for a long
long time so for example it's been used
for cell sorting and other techniques
that have been around for a long time
but the but the
but the differences and the advancement
comes in how this single cell technology
adopts this
these
protocols to understand the state of the
cell at expression level in a in a great
detail that has not been explored before
so it allows it allows to study new
biological questions in which stealth
cell specific changes in transcriptome
are important for example uh
cell type identification heterogeneity
of cell responses stuccity of
randomness of the gene expression or
pattern within the gene expression based
on the cell type and the inference of
regulatory networks gene regulatory
networks across the cells across the
time points so
these are very important applications of
uh single cell rna-seq
methods and yeah there are the key steps
that uh
key steps involving uh single cell rnac
data analysis is first you have to
extract the cells from the tissues and
isolate this cells one by one so this is
an extensive step and that that can be
executed by variety of different
technologies and professor sanjeev kumar
has ex
explained in detail and we will also go
over this in a very uh brief manner so
some steps follow a bulk sick rna
technology
like library preparation and
amplification these are common for both
but but the
but uh
but the way in which the single cells
are isolating the single cells uh is
performed is completely different from
how uh bulk uh rna-seq is handled ah
when using when when the samples are
extracted and rna is
profiled so um
so we have to then perform sequencing
using ht
high throughput or ngs sequencing
methods and then we have to generate a
structured data from these unstructured
fastq files and the structured data in
this case will be a count matrix and
which will be employed uh for downstream
analysis and various downstream analysis
as uh as you already had a lot of
introduction too so
so yeah so a single cell rna-seq
analysis includes several steps of
quality control and normalization due to
the small amount of material per cell
and the sensitivity of the sequencing
and it is best
to identify unreliable data sets and it
is best to exclude this from the
analysis of the arrest
analysis
from the downstream analysis and just
use the rest of the data
that can be uh normalized and that has
to be normalized to be
to be able to compare
and
yeah perform downstream analysis
um
so broadly speaking
yeah broadly uh broadly speaking the
analysis can be separated into three
different parts so first part deals with
the raw reads
by checking the quality and aligning it
to the reference genome and then the
second part deals with the cell specific
data by quality controlling the cell
specific data and normalizing and
eliminating the artifacts and then by
analyzing the resulting data sets for
differences and differential expression
patterns uh using clustering techniques
and network analysis which is best
suited for time course data so uh this
is this is just a very brief summary and
overview so this is going to be little
bit repetitive so let me breathe through
it a big part of single cell rna
sequencing profiling is is in the
preparation of data so how can you
separate cells for sequencing that is
that is the
bottleneck in which
based on which the single cell rna
sequencing technologies is
has been developed so the methods that
can be
the methods can be categorized into
different ways but the two most
important aspects are the approaches
that these methods rely on for capture
of the cells and quantification of the
cells so one is a micro well method
which
which performs or which utilizes a
series of micro scale wells that will be
or that are used to capture the cellular
materials the cells are isolated using
pipettes or laser captures and they are
placed separately in these microfluidic
wells so a major advantage of such
well-based methods
are
is that
they can be combined with fluorescent
activated cell sorting techniques and it
is possible to select cells based on the
surface markers and based on the
differences that one can observe in the
surface and this strategy is very useful
for situations where one wants to
isolate specific subset of cells
for sequencing so one of the main
drawbacks in such a methods or such
well-based method is that they are often
low throughput methods and the material
gets wasted a lot by separation and the
amount of work required to get a
personal um
output may be uh yeah may not be
considerable so
the another
technique based on which this uh
this capturing of cells is performed is
microfluidic platforms so uh they
provide a more um integrated system for
capturing cells and for carrying out
reactions that are necessary for library
preparations these platforms provide a
higher throughput than microbial based
platforms typically around only 10
percentage of the cells that are
captured in microfluidic platforms and
thus they are not appropriate
if one is dealing with rare cell types
and very small amounts of input so these
these these are the considerations that
you have to take or you have to make
when when you have to choose which
method or which platform that you want
to employ so moreover the chip that is
used for microfluidic platforms is
relatively expensive but since the
reactions can be carried out in smaller
volume and money can be saved on
reagents and other
chemicals so
the third one will be the idea behind a
droplet-based method is to
encapsulate us as uh as explained
multiple times by professor sanjeev
kumar also in the answers also in the
questions answer to the questions so is
to encapsulate each and individual cells
inside a nanoliter droplet together with
a bead so the bead as you have been
explained is loaded with enzymes that is
required to construct the library and in
particular each bead contains a unique
bar code which is attached to all the
reads originating from that particular
cell or from the specific cell thus all
the droplets can be pulled and sequenced
together and the reads can subsequently
be assigned to the cells of uh cells of
origin based on the unique bar course
that is cell dependent uh
or cell specific so the droplets perform
typically platforms typically have
highest throughput
of all the methods that we have
discussed so far and the library
preparation costs are on the order of
what less than one dollar per cell
but while the preparation costs are very
low the sequencing costs often will
become the limiting factor and thus a
typical experiment uh
is where is what uh typical experiment
should involve uh a lot of coverage uh
uh and hence uh
yeah and hence uh the cost will shoot up
in that
in that dimension
so uh
let's look at some of the quantification
approaches for a single cell rna
techniques or yeah
so for quantification approaches there
are two main approaches the full length
and tag based and the former
full-length
approaches tries to achieve the uniform
read coverage of each transcript because
the full length is being
used for the
used for the
quantification but in contrast tag-based
uh protocols or tag-based approaches
capture only either the five prime end
or the three prime end to which the tags
are attached so the choice of this
method is very important and has serious
implications in in the downstream
analysis and what types of analysis that
the data can be used for so because in
theory full-length protocols should
provide an even coverage of transcripts
but we will see or we shall see or we
often see that there are often biases in
this coverage so the main advantages the
main advantages of tag-based protocol
in contrast is that they can be combined
with
umis or unique molecular identifiers
which can help
help us improve the level of
quantification that one can achieve from
these analysis on the other hand
using these barcodes are using these
tag-based protocols to quantify the
genes
we are restricted to one end of the
transcript and this may reduce the map
ability and it may also make it harder
to distinguish different isoforms so
yeah
so the microfluidics based single cell
rnac can be covered in some of the major
steps that we are going to discuss in in
a very uh very brief uh um a few slides
two or three slides so first you have to
uh the preparation in the preparation
stage the cells are suspended to form
complex tissue uh from a cells are
suspended from
from a complex tissue to isolate these
cells into
different cell types
based on different isolation methods so
the synthesis of primers using barcoded
primer beads that attaches
to barcodes of these different cell
types so that will
actually
segregate us specify
which cell type or which
read that originate from which cell type
and then
then the microfluidic device
forms the major component which captures
the cells in oil droplets with which
contains barcoded beads and also which
contains a necessary components and
enzymes for
for
sequencing uh protocols or sequencing
methods so next
so
yeah the next the barcoding
of these molecules inside each cell each
cell has to be tagged by unique barcode
to identify
to identify those specific cells during
analysis methods because these barcodes
will become the
become the sequences or will become the
tag which will quantify those mrnas and
which will segregate those mrna to those
specific cells so this has to be
performed and
yeah the barcodes are added to the oil
droplets together with the cells and
buffered which breaks the cell membranes
and the mrnas are then attached to the
poly t tails of the barcodes um and then
these barcodes are then attached to
these
mrnas and then
and then they are proceeded for
sequencing so these barcodes actually
contain two two parts technically they
contain two parts one of the parts or
one component is the cell barcode um
which is uh yeah
which is uh similar to all the molecules
in one oil droplet so in in one droplet
we have one cell and all the mrna
molecules from that one cell will have
one unique
uh
cell barcode so that identifies
the relationship or that identifies the
source of that mrna molecules from that
particular cell and then you we have
unique molecular identifier which will
allow each mrna prior to pcr application
to have a separate barcode so these two
components will help in i will help in
first distinguishing mrna molecules for
for different or for specific cell types
and also will help in identifying
biases that are introduced during pcr
amplification methods so
yeah and then
we will have to yeah then the cells are
lysis lies and cell isis is performed
and rna hybridization is performed so
immediately after the droplet is formed
the each cell is lysed within the
droplet and its mrnas are released then
the mrnas are hybridized to the primers
on its uh micro particle surface surface
and then forms the stamp that professor
talked about single cell transcriptomes
attached to these micro particles and
after the mrnas are attached the
droplets are broken by adding necessary
reagents to destabilize the oil water
interface and the micro particles are
collected and then washed so the mrnas
are then reversed transcribed into dnas
together in in a reaction and
they form are forming a set of beads
called single cell transcriptomes
attached to micro particles these these
are the stamps in which the
the transcriptomes are attached to the
particles in the center so and then we
have to uh amplify these stamps and the
bar coded stamps can then be amplified
by pcr methods uh for
to necessary level that is required uh
for the high throughput mrna sequencing
methods so
so for sequencing and
analysis the resulting molecules are
then sequenced using
high capacity parallel sequencing and
the reads are first aligned to reference
genome to identify the gene of origin of
the cdna and then the reads are
organized by their
bar codes
yeah and they're okay it's a bit bigger
for some reason it's yeah
okay
so this is how
the pipeline can be
initiated in the t bio info platform
yes little bit better now so uh so these
molecules uh the resulting molecules are
then sequenced in high capacity parallel
sequencing as you as you know as you had
introduction to and then the reads are
first aligned to reference genome to
identify the gene of origin of the cdnas
and then the reads are organized by cell
barcodes and the number of mrna
transcripts that
constitute to each gene
for each cell is digitally counted so
this is where the umis and the cell
barcodes come into play and this will
help us in this will help us
avoid double counting of sequence reads
from the same mri grant transcripts and
then this will help us build a matrix of
digital gene expression measurements
that can be established for our or that
can be
uh leveraged for our further analysis so
to build the pipeline of scrna sequences
on uh
on t bioinfo platform we can select
appropriate algorithms that can be
chosen based on the sequencing data that
we have the steps involved the steps
include pre-processing and then mapping
and assigning
reads to transcripts and identify cells
using barcodes demultiplexing and then
proceed forward to
quantification artifact correction cell
to cell similarity identification
visualization so this this is
comparatively a long uh
a long pipeline
because of the necessary that single
cell rna technology
requires so that we should not we should
uh eliminate uh
we should eliminate uh
um
and normalize eliminate uh
outliers and normalize uh the um
normalized
uh the expression counts or normalize
the data uh to be able to be uh to be uh
to enable us to compare different cell
types so uh
yeah a consolidated pipeline will look
something like similar to this and at
the end of this pipeline you can submit
it and then
this is going to give us a
gene count matrix or count matrix
which can be downloaded from the
pipeline outputs
okay
yeah
so when you open this file so
technically when you open this file what
we have is
the columns of the table that we have
here are are the cells that are
represented by the cell barcodes uh in
the
in here
and in the row we have
jeans are ensemble ids and
in the intersection we have the
expression values of these genes each
are distinctly i mean of the genes for
each distinctly barcoded cell types and
that are given in
raw count values so the goal of the data
that is used for this analysis was to
identify different classes of cells this
this particular data that we are seeing
here is um is
is used to identify the different
classes of cells in the murine amygdala
tissue and thus
we will use known molecular marker genes
that are necessary to understand which
cell types are present in the table that
we just generated or the just the table
that is just generated from the
upstream analysis of
unstructured data to structured data so
we now restrict ourselves or we now
subset or select only those genes that
are known to be markers of different
cell types and we generate a smaller
table from this bigger larger table and
then this table is has to be technically
log normalized and then
subjected to principal component
analysis we can examine how the cells or
how distinct cell types uh are clustered
are separated into
different clusters
based on the marker gene so this this
marker gene is using
this segregation or this separation
based on the marker gene will give us uh
an overview or exploratory analysis
overview of how these cells uh separate
or cluster uh in the um
in the gene expression count data
distribution that we have
so more sophisticated visualization and
dimensionality reduction techniques like
psne and t-sne and umap will be able to
visualize and cluster specifically
distinct group of cells based on the
gene expression count that we have uh
obtained and that is that forms the
exploratory analysis and that that forms
a downstream analysis
after performing this exploratory
analysis we have to move towards
downstream analysis which will be more
sophisticated or which
will involve sophisticated algorithms so
once we have the count matrix and once
we have explored our data for for the
possibility and for the presence of
patterns within the data then we can
go and um
and employ a number of computational
methods that will help us to perform
downstream analysis and one such method
is uh one such package is curate and
yeah professor also uh talked about c
red so i will tell you how this can be
how this pipeline can be enabled or how
this pipeline now how different
components of this pipeline come
together in the in the single cell data
analysis that can be employed in t bio
info platform so the first first few
steps is to
create or to in
to generate a series objects for each
sample and then to check quality control
and and select only good quality cells
for each sample and then we have to
normalize the data for each sample and
then highly identify highly variable
features for each sample or highly
variable genes for each sample which
will
which will specifically define
the cell types so and then we have to
perform some integration and we have to
scale the data so that all the
expression counts or all the data from
multiple different
sequencing
cell types are in the similar scale and
then we we then um perform linear
dimensionality reduction methods like
pca and then we remove uh
yeah and then we remove
yeah
not not to remove and we perform this
dimensionality direction piece here to
reduce the number of dimensions that we
are going to analyze with and then we go
to
remove batch effects using harmony and
then we go
then we continue to cluster
key components of cluster cell types
find by finding neighbors and by finding
clusters and patterns within the
expression patterns and then we also
perform nonlinear dimensional detection
using new map and disney and that will
help us
that will help us and identify clusters
in the low dimensional space or
cluster in the reduced dimensional space
and these clusters can then be assigned
to different cell types based on the
marker genes that we have and then once
uh identified once these clusters are
identified and once these
different clusters are distinct clusters
are
identified from the umap and disney and
other clustering methods then we can
finally
establish contrast for which
differentially expressed genes can be
identified and essentially expert genes
can be
quantified and we can uh analyze and
interpret those genes that are uh that
forms or that form significantly
upregulated or down regulated on
for different uh uh distinct cell types
and uh yeah interpolate uh extrapolate
that analysis to uh relevant biological
interpretations so to select only good
quality cells one has to keep some of
the considerations in mind and one one
basic consideration or one important
consideration would
be the number of unique genes detected
in each cells and low quality cells or
empty droplets will often have very few
genes so
so filtering it out based on the number
of
unique genes will become an important
filter steps and uh yeah
while on the other hand uh cell doublets
or cell multiples may exist exhibit or
may
may display
an abnormally high gene count so you
have to make sure that you have to
filter out both the low quality cells
and
cells which have more than or droplets
which have more than one cells or fused
uh cells in them
so that they will not
interfere in our quantification of this
single cell rna
analysis so the percentage of reads that
that map to the mitochondrial genome
will also become very uh yeah will also
be
will also have to be removed and
this this will this will this is done
due to the fact that low quality cells
or dead cells often exhibit extensive
mitochondrial contamination so hence uh
to be uh to be careful and to ah to
eliminate those cells we have to
completely remove mitochondrial
contamination for example in this case
the percentage of mitochondrial
contamination in these two cells or in
these two
samples
is almost nil so we don't have to employ
that filter in this case uh
and and the next will become uh
standardization or next uh
the standardized variance plot of uh
of
can you help me yes thank you very much
so a standardized variance plot will
help us identify a subset of genes
that are
that are
found or that can be identified to be
expressed in a very high level from cell
to cell uh in a cell to cell variance um
yes in cell cell
differences or between different cells
and using this plot we can identify
those genes and um
and and employ those genes and analyze
and interpret and use those genes to
differentiate between the cell types and
differentiate between uh how
the distinct gene expression patterns
differ from differ
among those cell types and how it can be
used to
characterize and how it can be used to
explain the differences that we observe
in the cell type so identifying these
highly variable genes will become
extremely important
in our uh downstream analysis and and
next comes uh after this we uh comes um
one has to perform a non-linear
dimensionality reduction techniques or
methods like umap or tsp that can be
performed based on the top principle
components that is
that one calculates and we can use this
to visualize patterns in the data we can
use this to cluster
cells that have a similar expression
patterns and we can use this to identify
differences between these clusters uh
based on their segregation and
separation patterns so from these
identification of multiple different
clusters to annotation of clusters can
be carried out based on the cluster
specific marker genes
excuse me
yeah thank you sonalika so uh annotation
of clusters then can be carried out
based on the cluster specific top marker
genes which is used to identify cell
types in each cluster so this annotation
then after identifying or after
annotating these cluster types can be
transformed or transferred into the
clusters that we have identified or we
have generated in the um
in the umap or tsne non-reduction
dimensionality reduction methods and
they can be visualized to give us
segregation based on the gene expression
distribution so
these expression patterns that govern
the distinct cell types can be can also
be uh visualized as a um as a method or
as a
dot plot which represents uh simply a
percentage of expression levels based on
uh multiple samples of multiple cell
types or based on multiple uh
genes that we have and and this give
give us
this gives us the
genes that that are um
that are
regulated upregulated or downregulated
between different cell types so now that
we have identified distinct cell types
and
we have identified and
annotated existing cell types and we can
go on to perform a differentially
differential gene expression analysis
between the between multiple different
cell types and you based on these
comparisons one can
perform a detailed uh or can
one can extrapolate that to understand
the differences between the cell types
and one can perform a detailed
comparative analysis uh on the cell
types
or
or cells from different time points so
it depends on the sample that we have so
to
so far to summarize the analysis or the
logic of the analysis that one can one
one has to employ for single cell rna
analysis techniques let's take a look at
these simplified steps so we map the
reads and we get the bam or sam file
just like a regular rna-seq pipeline and
then we map the r codes and we produce a
table of molecular counts which is
similar to table of expression and then
we check for artifacts and then we
update the table of expression and then
we normalize the data and then a
similarity matrix
it has to be prepared and is calculated
based on the molecular counts and
based on the cell to cell distances
based on these molecular accounts of
this and that will that cell to cell
distances will form the basis in which
we can cluster or we can perform
trajectory analysis of our data so yeah
depending upon
uh depending upon whether
we want to find different groups of
cells
based on
whether we want to find different groups
of cells
that is present in the sample based on
the transcription profiles or whether we
want to analyze the cell development
stages of cell development
steps over time so clustering helps us
clustering like these methods help us
identify cells that are similar that
have similar expression patterns and
assigning them and assigns them to
distinct group as we have already seen
this is often performed using a
dimensionality reduction technique like
pca or disney and
trajectory analysis
is the one which is going to help us
identify which is going to help us
compare
cell differentiation or
cells that have different expression
level based on the differentiation time
and and based on the
based on
when or based on the
trajectory of these differentiation
times so
all these information analysis methods
i'll go back okay all these information
analysis methods and the logic behind
these methods and the choice of the
algorithms that you have to employ and
how to do on how to run these algorithms
and how to perform the downstream
analysis are discussed in much much
greater detail and in very
yeah
and in very
[Music]
logic based and the modular
way in the omics logic platform and i
encourage you all to go through and
go through the lessons and check that
out and
yeah experience
experience the single cell analysis
pipeline so that
you can develop
develop an appreciation for
for the
promise and for the potential that
singles rna-seq analysis has in
understanding and in answering some key
biological questions that uh bulk cell
rna analysis cannot be
employed for so i will take questions
now i think most of your questions would
have been uh cleared by professor
sanjeev kumar also
so
i'll take one or two questions and then
we have to move on to the next uh
we have to move on to our next
session
which will also be by me
so let's see if you have any burning
question in the chat box
what is the procedure and tools required
for mapping protein sequences heshika
that is not related to today's session
but uh
i will yeah
[Music]
there are
for mapping protein sequences okay
or for
for analyzing or for uh
aligning protein sequences with one
another so there are
specific threshold uh used to remove
mitochondrial contamination
uh
yes that's that's an excellent question
i i think it depends it depends and it
changes by data and one has to find out
how much of mitochondrial contamination
that we have and if at all if you have
any mitochondrial contamination then it
depends on
it depends on
our judgment to live out those samples
or it depends on our judgment to keep
those samples so if
yeah you have to employ some some sort
of yeah a sort of mitochondrial
contamination but
there are uh
and there are empirical
thresholds that are employed in the
analysis pipelines that will
help you out
with these conditions but
in the event of specific data set and or
in the event of specific uh
um
yeah uh
tailoring to specific data sets then
you'll be the we have to be the judge
and this comes with experience i think
yeah
any other queries
do you perform deg only on highly
variable genes and now i mean
technically it's not necessary but
we can imp uh we can just uh um
uh mention the contrast and then we can
perform uh differential gene
differential expression genes and the
output will be uh only highly variable
genes will will become uh will be
identified right i mean it's not
necessary that we have to perform the
eeg only on highly variable genes at
last how difficult it is to remove batch
effects it is
it is actually not i mean there are
techniques and there are algorithms to
remove batch effects and
the issue is
to identify or to
characterize the differences that we
observe between two
samples as batch effects right like uh
there has to be uniformity in these
batch effects based on which the based
on which these algorithms work and
if
if
if the
differences that we observe between two
uh batches or two to uh
to a subset of sample types is not
uniform or it doesn't form into any
uh any um yeah any uh
uh uniformity or any uh
uh um pattern then it is very difficult
to remove batch effects in in that
aspect also uh but yeah
it it it depends on it depends on the
fact that uh
um
there is a pattern two different batches
that are uh
to different samples that are uh
measured uh
by different uh users or different
methods so that is that is the main
line right
if there is no uniformity or if the
signal to noise ratio is very low then
it is also very difficult to remove
batch effects and we might
see the detrimental effects of those in
the downstream analysis
okay if
yeah if there is no more questions then
we will uh
move forward
and let's
uh
yes okay so the next session for today
is titled actually as uh genomics in
agriculture but
i will actually take the liberty to
change it into omics in agriculture or
into the promise of multiple omics
technology in agriculture that
one can
one will
have or one will get an introduction to
from
from a very short presentation today so
i welcome you all one more time and
before i even began i want to uh be
before i even began to introduce the
topics and introduce different aspects
of the topics i want to show you uh the
complexity of um bringing or of
considering uh plants into or mixed
studies or the complexity that the
interaction that the plants uh as an
organism that it has with these
surroundings brings to the ohmic studies
in order to the familiar omics like
genomics metagenomics transcriptomics
and proteomics and even metabolomics
there are a couple of omics that we do
not
often hear about so one of them is um
one of them is
volatilomics which is
considered as a subset of metabolomics
this characterizes
excuse me this comprehensively
characterizes
profiling of high vapor pressure
compounds that can be released from the
plants so this becomes very important in
the event of stress or in the event of
other
yeah
natural uh situation for which the
plants will have different uh signature
of uh volatile omics consider compared
to the ordinary volatilomics signature
so similarly spectronomics is a study of
photosynthetic functional traits of the
plants and this is used to better
understand both the natural variability
in vegetation and function and the
variability in the function in response
to environmental stress and change so it
becomes very important because i want to
enlighten you that
before
before our normal methods of
understanding the green fluorescence or
understanding the greenliness or
greenness of the plants
our farmers use this
technique these spectronomics but not
directly but indirectly by judging how
green or judging the
fluorescence of the plants and when to
when to
supplement it with necessary pesticide
or when to supplement it with the
necessary
irrigation pattern and this this this
study or this omnic will become
extremely important because
not all the plans can be analyzed and
not all of them
can be analyzed in the event of mass
production or in the event of
a mass um
optimization so uh a remote sensing
possibility of economics is being
explored uh and unders
and the satellite satellite based uh
identification of different plants
species based on spectronomics is also
being employed or is also being explored
currently so these are these are all
very rare fields which
require
extremely high specialization and and
they are being currently explored in
multiple parts of the world and that's
where uh
plant uh omics is actually moving to
so
so to give you some sense of
introduction we all we all know that
agriculture is not
not only a major occupation for few
nations but also it's a way of life it's
a way of culture it's a way of custom
for majority of the
countries and majority of the nations
majority of the continents so cereals
and food products and like rice wheat
barley corn and others have always been
considered important food in human
populations over different continents
and different era so for thousands and
thousands of years
people are using breeding technologies
people are using selective breeding
people are using domestic selection uh
based on that
based on the different characteristics
and phenotypes of these crops
with and then based on the selective
regulation and selective breeding of
these characteristics they would
continue to breed to
reach or to attain
wanted characteristics that is going to
maximize
the yield or maximize the survival
ability of the plants in the condition
in which they are
grown for so significant progress
has been completed in taste nutritional
value and productivity but other uh
i mean progress in other areas like uh
like stress response or like uh
um
yeah like
response to stress or response to
salinity or response to uh high heat
which is very uh i mean
increase exposure to heat and light and
dust which which becomes extremely
important in the event of climate change
and and
these areas are these progresses in
these areas are being currently explored
in uh
in great detail so last 10 years
the last 10 years were considered
to be the new era of bioinformatics and
computational biology in the
life science section on the plant
science plant light scene section so
involvement of these computer science in
the area of plant biology has changed
the way people usually do research
related to plants in in previous decades
so groundbreaking progress in in
sequencing technology and groundbreaking
path breaking analytical technologies
that has evolved in the few last few
years uh has made a co made these uh
made this approach cost effective and
nowadays it is extremely common for any
experimental or agro based experimental
lab to use
sequencing based methods to study and to
uh
and to optimize and to develop
characteristics and phenotypes that are
extremely important in the
in the plant production uh field so
so in in this
in this
continuity a comparative genomics of the
models
comparative genome genomics of the
species
for
between a model plant and between
non-model plan can be extremely helpful
in discovering organization of these
genes and comparative comparison between
the organization of the genes with
respect to each other and comparison
between
between how the information is
transferred from the model crop systems
usually arabidopsis are usually
much
less
plant species with a lower complexity
and how the
information and organization of this
complex information is being transformed
transferred from the model systems to
food crop systems like rice or like
maize or like wheat
in the event of water crisis or in the
event of salinity so according to
accordingly the use of multiple omics
and the use of genomics and
bioinformatics and the combination
bioinformatics in combination with
selective breeding would likely to
increase the ability of these
crop species to being used as
biofuel feedstocks and therefore
by employing
these genomics and multiple omics
technologies in combination with
selective breeding will increase the use
of renewable energy in the modern
society and help us thrive
better in for the future challenges that
we have
so
one of the useful applications are
successful applications to say
that that has
that that
that is
directly that one can directly evidenced
evidence from the omics of the
application of omics and gene based
editing
in agriculture is the pest control for
crops using specific genes from bacillus
turin genesis so this particular gene
can help help
control number of serious pests that
have been successfully
employed and successfully
tested in cotton mason potato so when
when these
crops get
these bt or bacillus syringes genes
inserted into their genome so they
develop ability to resist or to deter
insect outbreak and and to
and that
and
and also
resist pests that are see that seriously
decrease or that seriously harm these
plants and crops and thereby
increasing and improving the nutritional
quality of these crops such as efforts
has been employed in in
in enormous scales in western countries
like uh us in australia this picture is
actually from from an australian
university which employs or which uh
published this particular result so
yeah
so this uh
so such efforts and such
characterization
of such possibilities of gene editing is
also
carried out in in multiple labs in india
to name a few napgr and other labs in
india is also exploring the possibility
of identifying and understanding the
genetic variety of uh
crops that are specific to india and in
comparison to crops that are found
elsewhere and
scientists have actually succeeded in
transferring genes to rice
to enlarge the levels of vitamin a for
example enlarged levels of supplements
and nutrients that rice can provide and
to enlarge levels of iron and other
micronutrients and this success
does have a deep impact and
in in
in reducing incidence of anemia and
reducing incidence of deficiency in
vitamin deficiency and in iron
deficiency and even some in some extreme
cases uh blindness that are caused in
some um yeah in some specific parts of
the world so
so another such example and this this
this comes from an apgr example also is
is in developing cereal varieties that
have greater tolerance to soil
alkalinity and
they are they are also been um
constantly uh uh yeah uh explored for
their ability to uh
uh to deter or to uh
to grow in in the presence of ion
toxicities in the soil and these uh and
the variety of different cereals and
chickpea varieties that will be uh that
are free of aluminium that are free of
other uh toxics uh
toxicities and uh and and and uh other
uh
uh
increased uh micronutrients products uh
that are being also uh constantly
explored that are being also constantly
uh checked for um so these varieties and
and studies in this direction actually
leads
agriculture
to and leaves agriculture too and
expands the expands the reach of
agriculture to poorer soil areas and
therefore adding much more agricultural
land to the global production base which
for which the demand is going to
increase in the coming years
because of twofold so one fold because
of increasing population and the second
fold because of the climate change many
existing
soil areas are existing rich soil areas
are constantly being converted into
wasteland or poor soil areas because of
the changes in environmental conditions
so
researchers and efforts in in such
direction is extremely important and are
being
handled with utmost care in multiple
countries to name a few india africa
australia
europe and et cetera et cetera so uh to
go with the flow another important
application is in the area of
metagenomics in agriculture so this has
shown
extremely
yeah this this is shown to be extremely
appropriate for um
for identifying and for representing
complex patterns of interaction that is
occurring among the microorganisms that
populate the soil and also populate the
plant tissues and also populate
different organs of the plants so
moreover metagenomics also showed to be
extremely useful in tracing or in
tracing or in
in
in
converting
converting the composition where one
identifies the composition to be poor or
where one identify the composition to be
a presence
composition to be composed of presence
composition to be uh
composition that is identified to be
present for virulent
factors and and by transforming uh these
uh um
microbial
uh microbial society within the soil or
within the different organs of these
plants one can actually bring back the
uh natural
defense system of the plants to fight
away um specific uh
uh specific stress condition that the
plants are undergoing this this is this
is also an extremely
upcoming era because this era is already
been
underlined as meta genomics or microbial
era where
the application of metagenomics in
various
fields and in way and their impact in
various
research areas are being constantly
explored and are
developed and the methods and profiling
methods and the analysis methods are
being
constantly researched on and developed
further so in in this respect one more
comics that is metabolomics uh is a very
uh chemistry based or chemi uh
based uh emerging field in the world of
omics and it is normally used to scan
all the metabolites present in the
sample using sophisticated instruments
and
and
this will also this also becomes an
extremely important uh
uh field where as i have already
mentioned the volatilomics is is already
grow getting gathering lot of uh
acceleration and uh
um
and uh
gaining lot of popularity in the plant
biotechnology uh area so
to to summarize in a nutshell uh the
goal of plant genomics is basically to
understand the genetic and molecular
basis of all biological processing
plants and this will help us
relate to this into the complex
interaction that the plant species has
with its uh with this environment and
this will help us understand um
what is essential in allowing
what is essential for the plants
for efficient maintenance of the
biological resources and in and for
developing new
varieties that will help us
improve the quality and that will help
us reduce the economic burden and that
will help us reduce the environmental
burden that we put on the soil and that
will help us expand the agricultural
reach to other uh
to other countries where agriculture is
not being the
dominant
food yielding uh source uh due to other
various reasons while there have been uh
successes in identifying uh critical
genes or ah and and in identifying or
introducing a new genes as we had
already mentioned before
for agrogenomic improvement the
mechanistic understanding of how
such an effort is functioning is is
still
on how such an effort
or such an such
[Music]
process uh actually helps uh in
developing or in in maintaining specific
agricultural phenotypes is is actually
lagging because of the complexity of the
plants uh genome systems and plant
cellular system
presents itself on the complexity that
actually
increases
with the presence of its
interaction or complex interaction with
its environment and and non-uniform
non-uniformity of this interaction also
plays a lot of uh
part in in in
in a
in
a in a consensus effort like whole
genome project effort
that that is still lagging for
plant sciences so that is in in this
context uh instead of studying uh
genomics or instead of studying
metagenomics or instead of studying
metabolomics as a as a separate entity
just like how
cancer genomics are cancer multi omics
has been employed to understand
cancer and to fight away fight off
this deadly disease there is a need to
take the leave from clinical
applications of bioinformatics and
multi-omics integration
in human
disease
translation science and there is a need
to take that and there is a need to
integrate information across
different hierarchy and different
biological sales
scales
so as an example
from left to right we can have the
genomics genome sequence and we can have
the epigenomic marks and we can have a
chromosomal conformation of this plancy
plant's genome and we can have
transcriptomics data and we can also
we have to and we not we can but we have
to uh consider the plant phenotype which
which is a subject of genetic uh
selection for thousands and thousands
and thousands of years and we also have
to take the environmental and the
ecosystem factors and the challenge in
such a setup is to
is to how
practically and conceptually integrate
all these multiple different information
uh so that that information will help us
help us improve the uh improve the plant
uh output or improve improve the
quality of the
agricultural products that we are
actually developing so the challenge
is there and hence uh because of these
challenges there is an exciting
opportunity to do such multiple levels
of data integration um
and and to uh
to improve include uh some of the uh
other omics that i actually missed out
like metabolism and like other uh
um environmental data also to understand
how plants and how uh the agricultural
product productivity
changes uh depending upon these
different omics platform so
that is that is it for uh for the
introduction to
agree ugly genomics or that is what it
is called agrigenomics are omics in
multiple
omics in applications to multiple
agricultural
efforts and
to introduce you to such
such a system or to introduce you to
genomics and genomic analysis
in agricultural background the omixlogic
platform has a project that specifically
deals with
gene expression analysis and analysis of
gene expression data in potato to
understand the genes that will
that forms the biomarker that forms the
basis for developing a drought
resistance in specific species of potato
so i encourage and i um
direct you all to go through this very
short lesson and that will really help
you
appreciate and understand the
ugly genomics
effort and agree on the
inference that one can gain from
applying bioinformatics analysis and
applying genomics analysis to uh
agricultural
system so i can take some questions here
if you have any
and yeah
please type in your questions in the
chat box
and thank you for your patience and
thank you for your listening
and looking forward to exciting
discussion
please go ahead
are you still there
yes we can hear you
do we have any questions if yes you can
either unmute yourself and take your
question or put them in the chat box
so yeah if there are no questions then i
can i can continue to tell some of the
challenges that uh how is a chloroplast
genomics how is how is it is how it is
engineered okay there are specific ways
to engineer i did not go into
biotechnical uh way in which this genome
is engineered but one can use crispr
casp9 technology also so that is the uh
upcoming uh way in which you can
genetically engineer plant sequences and
uh
one more ohm that i actually missed out
is
in contact with what uh lita mahapatra
has
which is called a plasto so that
actually sequences the um
chloroplast genome of the plant
sequences and this brings in its own
genetic complexity in itself so
generally
the complexity of uh up applying these
omics data analysis to plant sequences
is manifold like
i mean
to begin with there is not a lot of uh
reference genome that one can identify
and
and since the nature of the plants and
it's because of its
interaction to its environment and even
closely related species can have
multiple variations in their gene
sequences and we cannot get away with
applying uh
sequence from
one species to the other species even
though
they are from the same genus so so these
uh these these issues are still there
and then uh obviously
the issues related to repeated sequences
are also there because uh because uh
plans are uh
are subjected uh the planet's sequences
are subjected to um
a lot of viral attacks and a lot of so
they develop their own
defense mechanisms and they they have a
lot of jumping genes in their
genomes and then this will uh translate
into repeated sequences in the uh
genomes uh whole genome sequences and
repeated sequence of the genome that is
going to complicate our mapping uh
process as well so in that event in the
last let's say five years or six years
or even more than that uh long read
technologies have actually enabled or
actually helped uh or actually revived
uh these
ugly genomics effort even more and and
in the last two years you can see lot of
reviews connecting
connecting specific efforts in
increasing the number of uh whole genome
sequences that we have for the plant
sequences with
emphasis specifically put into
agricultural plants
and
any any other question in this regard
yes yes exactly so i think comparative
genomics is very challenging when it
comes to plant genomics you agree
because exactly that's what i actually
touched upon because because of the lack
of uh
or because of the lower availability of
the reference genomes we are always left
to
perform comparative genomics only among
the known genomes or among the known
varieties or with the model system which
which is always not a preferred case and
you know in a general case so uh so um
bioinformatics analysis have come a long
way
for
for translational sciences and
translational studies that involve human
samples and human uh system but it has
it still has a long way to go
for agricultural in in the agricultural
one but remember another
i also want to point to you that i i did
not even
describe or did not even take uh the tip
of the iceberg the the data and the
potential is huge
because ugly genome makes does not only
concern plants it also concerns the
cattle that we are using too
that we are using and it also concerns
the
different cycles or different uh
complex interaction patterns of
different plants that one can
cultivate one after the other so so
there is a lot of
potential knowledge to be tapped on
there is a lot of potential
information to be gained on and yeah and
the research field in this area is
currently
only starting to blossom to
say
uh in a very related terminology
and
any other queries in this aspect if if
you do not have any questions or even
yeah
if you have any comments you are welcome
to pass it on
or i can hand over the session to
sunalika now
i think it's malika here so
yeah yes i'm here
okay thank you
so there is also uh saying something
could you please go through that just
before we talk
yeah yeah i told right i i actually uh
answered that
but yes yes it
uh is availability of uh whole genome
sequences and
yeah
thank you
and currently the growing area is
metagenomics
and uh yeah so that is easy to capture
and that is going to develop a lot of uh
analysis and lot of technologies related
to metagenomics and
not only in soil samples also as i
mentioned in
in metagenomic samples between
different organs of the plants like
between the tip of the shoot between the
tip of the between the root and between
different uh yeah
this one so that is also extremely
fast growing field apparently
so yeah
then i i will hand it over to sunalika
for further
yeah
thank you so much dr raghav
thank you sir thank you for such an
amazing session and
thank you so much dr sanjeev as well it
was
very insightful both of the sessions
were amazing and the participants did
definitely learn a lot and for everyone
i would like to thank you all for being
a part of this today workshop
and what all we went through in these
two days of workshop was just a glimpse
of how we can expand more and learn more
practice more and get some good hands-on
with the pipelines on the server uh in
the program genomics data analysis so
the this was just the beginning to get
you all started
so uh now the actual program that is a
one month long mentor guided program
which will have nine live sessions
commences on 18th of january and this
program will conclude on uh 18th of
february
so this is the program page
and for those who have joined
the workshop
uh today and were not present yesterday
for them i just like to go through this
program page once again and tell you
that on this program page you'll be able
to find all the session details the
schedule has been very well defined on
the program page itself with all the
session details model topics will be
covered and also the associated online
resources that includes the coursework
or the lessons from the portal itself
that has to be completed as a part of
each of this session
and on the program page itself if you
have not registered yourself for this
particular program then you will find
three different levels that includes big
note and intimidate and an advanced
level
so you can pick the level that you would
like to enroll for based on the
prerequisites that are being mentioned
here so there are various resources that
are being given as these three different
subscription types in the beginner level
you'll be able to definitely be a part
of these group meetings that we'll be
having in the intimidate level uh you
will also be able to
have a one-on-one mentor support and an
advanced level will help you get some
extra time a month i like an extra month
to work on your independent research
project so that is the difference
between these three different levels and
we also have great uh scholarship
opportunities for the participants so if
you are one of those who are seeking a
good scholarship to join this particular
program
then i am sharing the scholarship form
in the chat box right away please feel
free to fill out the scholarship form
and reach out to miss pashthar
on marketing adherate omixojic.com
and she'll be able to assist you with
your
uh enjoyment for this wonderful program
that we are about to begin
after the completion of the program the
participants will be getting the
certificate as well on their profile and
the program page also lists the program
courses and the project library that
will come handy to all the program
participants as a part of this
program
so that was all about how you can enroll
yourself for the program and get started
with a good learning and some good
hands-on with genomic data analysis and
come up with an independent research
project that could have various outcomes
uh one of which would be a publication
or a poster presentation
and also a literature review could one
of the could be one of the very basics
of basic outcome for a graduate or
undergraduate student so that was all
that we he wanted to share with all of
you and now i would like to um
leave the stage open for everyone if you
have any questions please put in the
chat box some mentors are here to take
any of the questions that you might be
having
okay if there are no questions then uh i
would like to thank you all once again
for being a part of the two day workshop
and we will now be meeting you all um on
january 18th when the program begins
thank you so much dr raghavendran and